[Música]
en alemania ya son 135 los fallecidos
por las inundaciones que han afectado el
oeste del país en donde se espera la
distribución de ayudas los países bajos
luxemburgo y bélgica también resultaron
afectados este último país fue visitado
por la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen
un primer caso de positivo de kobe 19
fue registrado en la villa olímpica de
tokio 2020 se trata de un residente y no
de un deportista competidor según
confirmaron los organizadores del evento
que afirmaron que esto no impedirá el
inicio de las justas deportivas el
próximo 23 de julio
y el presidente de siria bachar al asad
a tomó posesión para su cuarto período
presidencial consecutivo que se
extenderá por siete años a lasarte quien
lleva ya más de 20 años en el poder
gobernar a un país devastado por 10 años
de guerra civil inmerso en una profunda
crisis económica sanitaria por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y humanitaria
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora vamos a comenzar en el
continente europeo las intensas lluvias
en alemania y en bélgica se han cobrado
ya más de 157 vidas 135 de ellas
solamente en alemania en donde también
hay un centenar de desaparecidos en este
país tanto los ciudadanos como los
militares han dado inicio a las labores
de limpieza para extraer el agua de las
viviendas y también para recuperar
algunos vehículos que fueron arrastrados
por el agua en bélgica el primer
ministro de ese país a lección de hoop
visitó las zonas afectadas en compañía
de la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen de otra parte en el
reino de los países bajos se esperan
desbordamientos de varios diques en las
próximas horas en el sur del país natal
y aplazar nos cuenta más
rescatistas con lanchas y buzos que
barren autopistas inundadas en búsqueda
de víctimas y desaparecidos
a medida que cesan las intensas lluvias
en alemania los equipos de rescate
intensifican sus labores más que nunca
ciudades y viviendas del oeste del país
continúan inundadas en el peor desastre
natural en medio siglo el presidente
alemán frank walter steinmeier reiteró
su apoyo a los más afectados las
regiones y el gobierno federal dejaron
en claro desde muy temprano que aquellos
que han perdido tanto que han tenido
tantas pérdidas les proporcionaremos
ayuda tienen hasta el momento alemania
reporta más de 130 muertos y cientos de
desaparecidos en distintos sectores los
propios vecinos se han unido a las
labores de limpieza en otras el ejército
utiliza tanques para extraer agua de
viviendas y vehículos en la vecina
bélgica son más de 20 los fallecidos el
primer ministro del país alexandr de
ccoo junto a la presidenta de la
comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen visitó la ciudad de
rockford asolada por las inundaciones
y he visto esto en la televisión pero
ver la angustia humana de verdad es
conmovedor y esta angustia humana no la
vemos de la misma manera en la
televisión vemos mucha solidaridad pero
sigue siendo necesaria mucha ayuda entre
tanto los servicios de emergencia de
países bajos permanecen en alerta máxima
los ríos desbordados temen fuertes
inundaciones en toda la provincia sureña
de limburg o ya es el caso de algunas
urbes como la ciudad de bell no
las calles de parís la capital francesa
fueron tomadas por cerca de 1.500
manifestantes que rechazan el decreto de
la vacunación obligatoria y también las
restricciones que conllevaría no
inocularse contra el kobe 19 dicha
medida por el momento solo involucra al
personal de salud para que pueda
trabajar los manifestantes también
rechazan la extensión del certificado
sanitario en actividades de la vida
cotidiana como por ejemplo acceder a los
espacios públicos el gobierno francés
indicó que ha tenido que tomar esta
decisión ante el repunte de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 en el país que ha
llegado a registrar hasta 11 mil casos
positivos en sólo espacios de 24 horas
la mayoría de ellos ante el avance de la
variante delta
y a partir de mañana de domingo
precisamente francia exigirá a los
viajeros no vacunados que lleguen de
españa el reino unido portugal los
países bajos grecia y chipre un test de
coronavirus de un máximo de 24 horas
la medida es según el gobierno de ese
país se debe a los aumentos de los casos
de kobe 19 a nivel mundial pero
particularmente en francia debido al
avance de la variante delta mientras
tanto la lista de países de color rojo
también se extiende a otras naciones
como cuba túnez indonesia y mozambique
los ciudadanos de esos países sólo
podrán ingresar a francia si viajan por
un motivo imperativo
y los organizadores de los próximos
juegos olímpicos en reportaron el primer
caso de kobe 19 al interior de la villa
olímpica los primeros detalles dados por
los organizadores indican que se trata
de un extranjero no es uno de los
deportistas y ya fue puesto en
cuarentena el comité olímpico aseguró
que este caso positivo no pone en riesgo
a los demás deportistas y tampoco pone
en riesgo el inicio de estas justas
deportivas el próximo 23 de julio
valentina torre sánchez nos cuenta más
en el siguiente informe
es el primer positivo en la villa
olímpica y encendió las alarmas a seis
días de la inauguración del evento se
trata de un integrante de una de las
delegaciones extranjeras que dio
positivo el viernes
hemos tomado medidas para asegurar la
seguridad en la villa olímpica con la
situación actual que surjan casos
positivos es en sí mismo algo que
debemos asumir como tal tomaremos las
medidas adecuadas para que los atletas
que residen allí puedan sentirse seguros
su testing por seguridad no se informó
su nombre ni su nacionalidad los
organizadores sólo señalaron que no es
un atleta y agregaron que están
recopilando información sobre los
contactos cercanos que pudo tener al
caer pese a que la villa olímpica
ubicada en una de las islas artificiales
de la bahía de tokio albergará a unos 11
mil deportistas e integrantes de
delegaciones el presidente del comité
olímpico internacional aseguró que este
primer positivo no supone riesgo para
los deportistas asimismo pidió al pueblo
japonés que acoja a los atletas ante las
constantes protestas para cancelar el
evento
estamos al tanto del escepticismo que
tienen muchas personas aquí en japón nos
enteramos por los medios y lo de
liberamos por eso llamó al pueblo
japonés a acoger a estos atletas en la
competencia de sus vidas de este sábado
también fueron reportados 14 nuevos
casos de personas vinculadas a los
olímpicos dos de integrantes de medios
de comunicación siete de contratistas y
cinco de personal de logística lo que le
lleva más de 40 el total de positivos
registrados durante el mes de julio de
personas relacionadas con el evento
cambiamos de tema vamos hasta medio
oriente por cuarta vez consecutiva
bashar al asad a tomó posesión como
presidente de siria en un nuevo mandato
de siete años de duración después de
triunfar con un cuestionado 95 por
ciento de los votos en unas elecciones
muy criticadas por la comunidad
internacional
bashar al-assad continuará gobernando un
país devastado por 10 años de guerra
civil y en una profunda crisis económica
sanitaria también debido a la pandemia
del cobi 19 y también en una crisis
humanitaria debido a la falta de
alimentos y al desplazamiento de los
ciudadanos 21 años han pasado desde que
bashar al-assad fue proclamado
presidente por primera vez este sábado y
por cuarta ocasión prestó juramento para
iniciar un nuevo mandato
juro en nombre de dios que vamos a
respetar la constitución siria las leyes
de este país y su estructura republicana
vamos a velar por los intereses del
pueblo y sus libertades proteger la
soberanía de la nación su independencia
su libertad y la defensa de su
territorio y sin embargo su cuarta
investidura se presenta en un contexto
donde el país sigue sumido por los
estragos de la guerra más del 80 por
ciento de la población vive en la
pobreza y según el programa mundial de
alimentos 12.4 millones de personas
luchan por abastecerse de comida cada
día la investidura se dio después de las
elecciones del 26 de mayo deslegitimadas
por varios países como eeuu francia y
gran bretaña en las que basilio 95.1 por
ciento de los votos además de la crisis
social en este nuevo período el
ejecutivo tendrá que retomar el control
de territorios bajo el mandato de grupos
armados el noreste del país es
controlado por la facilidad al qaeda y
su salida desde y clic mientras que las
fuerzas kurdas mantienen el dominio en
buena parte del este y tour que sus
representantes sirios controlan la parte
del norte
en su nuevo mandato al asad prometió
trabajar por mantener estos territorios
como parte de siria y darle prioridad al
proceso de reconciliación en el país
desde el comienzo de la guerra más de
medio millón de personas han sido
asesinadas y más de 12 millones han sido
desplazadas
en otros temas políticos de afganistán
se reunieron nuevamente con
representantes del grupo talibán en la
ciudad de doha la capital de qatar en un
nuevo intento de impulsar esa mesa de
negociaciones iniciadas ya el año pasado
y que no ha tenido resultados ha
redundado incluso en una mayor presencia
del territorio por parte de los
insurgentes del talibán ante la retirada
de las tropas internacionales la agencia
de la onu para los refugiados se estima
que unos 3.5 millones de ciudadanos
afganos han sido desplazados internos o
han tenido que abandonar el país para
buscar refugio en otras naciones
con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias aquí en francés 24 recuerde que
puede encontrar más información en
france 24 punto com en las redes
sociales y también en la app puede
seguir con nuestra programación buenas
tardes
[Música]